I must have been drinking too much. I'm
trying hard. [Music] Jingi-san told me to do it, right? Is it really
possible to control your power by doing this? I can do it, I can do it. Concentrate and write it down
in kanji.
What is it?  Didn't I tell you about that? The
vein of life is like the energy of life that flows at the bottom of the earth. It's the
energy of life that flows under the demons in a huge swell. That's what we need.
In your case, you're in a situation where you don't have enough of your own power, so the more you
rely on that big power, the more stable it becomes.Try the
technique I taught you the other day and see how much
control you've gained.
Show it to your master
[Music]
I often make mistakes and rule everything and make them fight, and the
end is bad. I
can't even do such an elementary technique properly. I'm worried about the future. It can't be helped, right? I just learned it the other day,
so let's do it here.
Master will show you an example, and you'll see that he has to master
everything by controlling all things, not fighting, and the
dirt that prisoners hate, and that he has
made it this far with the art of packing.
This guy listens to everything I say, and he's a
genius who absorbs nearby switches and operates semi-permanently. No, I just want to
control my power, but that's
how it is. You should train steadily, too.